the small historic town of antweiler was
built along the very same river
that last week tried to destroy it
bridges smashed roads torn up and dozens
of homes in tatters
this small community where everyone
knows each other
has been joined by scores of strangers
volunteers and fire crews helping with
the cleanup
dirk mashin's home is 150 years old
part of it may have to be pulled down
how high did the water come in here
the water came about two meters in here
yeah what happened here the water
pressure
smashed the refrigerator into the wall
the high pressure pretty cottages a
little higher up
stand in stock contrast to those nearer
the river
the flood waters lashing out at village
residents from the present
and the past
the neighborhood spirit here is strong
like at this makeshift crisis center
wow look at this huge amount of clothes
where did the idea come from for all
this from the church
and from the people in the in the
village
it is a village which until last week
attracted tourists wanting a taste of
serene
rural life it is badly scarred but will
heal through the sheer strength of its
community
jonathan samuels sky news and fire